it's another new year how many of you
have written down your new year's
resolution here's a fun fact every
single year losing weight is the number
one resolution across the world
everybody wants to be slimmer healthier
it better or to feel better but before
we continue grab your phone and download
the life Sam app watch this video
through and follow along all right see
if this sounds familiar for the first
month
everything seems on track you're doing
really well and you're hitting all your
fitness goals come February you fall off
the wagon and you're forgotten all the
new year's resolution you wrote a month
ago and you sort of like just push it
aside and tell yourself I'll try it
again next year and the same cycle
repeats again for another year and
another year and this goes on for
several years and you're stuck in the
same situation I don't want this for you
I want you to succeed so I'm going to
teach you seven really simple but
effective steps to start a successful
fitness resolution let's do this
together all right the first step is to
actually write it down most of the time
we tell our self what we want to achieve
without physically writing it down it
has been proven that people who write
down their goals are more likely to
achieve them by over 70% so I want you
to start getting into the habit of
taking notes you can either write it in
your journal or if you're more of a
mobile person then take note in your
mobile and make that your wallpaper
don't just write your fitness resolution
and leave the rest of the pages blank
start to develop the habit of journaling
every single day it can be a list of
things to accomplish for the day three
things you're grateful for and three
things that you can improve on the habit
of keeping a journal will drive you to
reflect it will remind you of your goals
hence you are more likely to stay
committed and achieve success the next
question is what should I write that
leads on to my next step be detailed but
at the same time don't stress out about
it there is no right or wrong and
sometimes you would even know what you
want until you start writing things down
so the life some app is a great app to
help you achieve your fitness and
lifestyle goals by offering you a
personalized guide to healthy living so
when you sign up
it'll ask you what your fitness goal is
is it to be healthier to lose weight or
to gain weight instead of just saying my
goal is to lose weight let's dive deeper
my goal is to lose 20 kilos this year
now go ahead and key in your current
weight and key in your goal weight
that's a great start now let's dive in
even deeper and break it down so my goal
is to lose 20 kilos this year and I'm
going to achieve that by losing an
average of 0.5 kilos or week go ahead
and set your goal when you add quantity
to your goals and break them down to
smaller goals you're able to measure and
track and to ensure success so rather
than looking at a bigger goal of losing
20 kilos which can be overwhelming and
scary you're focusing on the small
achievable goal of 0.5 kilos per week so
guys setting a goal is only one small
part of the puzzle the next step is the
most important step have an action plan
how are you going to achieve your goal
what do you have to do more off what do
you have to sacrifice so right now I
want you to create two columns the first
column is the action column what do you
have to do more off the second column is
the give column what do you have to give
up so the action column can be I'll hit
the gym at least three times weekly I'll
aim to cook two healthy meals a day the
gift column can be out order take away
only once a week I'll have to wake up an
hour earlier to hit the gym I'll only go
out for a drink once a week it doesn't
have to be a long list but rather a
short list which you can focus on and
turn them into positive habits so with
the lifestyle app when you sign up for
lose weight you also have access to a
three-week meal plan with four meals per
day the recipes are really easy to cook
and contain
maximum of five ingredients you also
have a meal planner where you can see
and plan what to eat for the coming days
you also get a shopping list to bring
with you to the grocery store way
cheaper than any other meal plants out
there on top of that you'll start to
learn what healthy ingredients are and
the right portion servings and you will
also get to cheat on some days and still
meet your goal hey I believe it's all
about balance and moderation one of the
key factors when it comes to lifestyle
change is planning and keeping it simple
with a really clear and easy meal plan
and also shopping lists it will reduce
your chances of buying junk when you're
out doing your grocery shopping the next
step is to turn your resolution into a
habit now that you have a clear goal and
an action plan the next step is to put
them into practice daily and to turn
them into positive habits the best way
to break bad habits it's not to try to
stop doing them
because by doing that you're
subconsciously giving your bad habits
even more attention we plan to set
negative goals and focus on the things
we're not going to do for instance I'm
not going to eat a junk food
I'm not going to binge eat instead of
focusing on what you're not going to do
and fight against it the goal is to
create new positive habit and focus on
what you're going to do so for instance
I'm going to have at least five servings
of vegetables every day I'm going to
drink at least eight glasses of water
and I'm going to hit the gym at least
three times weekly rewire your mind
focus on your new positive habits and
work on them daily it's about making
slow and subtle changes to give your
body and mind the time to adapt and
adjust so I've created a video on 10
steps to break that habit and to achieve
your goal do check it out another great
feature I love about the lifestyle app
is the ability to track your fitness
progress every time you consume one
serving of vegetables hit the veggie
icon
every time you drink one cup of water
hit the drink icon take pictures and
track all your food intake and also your
daily activities it's a really fun and
effective way to remind you to stick to
your action plan and at the end of the
day when you review your progress you
can either look for ways to improve or
celebrate small successes along the way
if you commit to check your progress
every single day eventually eating well
and staying active will become part of
you step number six share and be part of
a community every year I'll drag my list
and exchange it with a close friend I
truly believe that when you share your
goals with like-minded people it will
give you a sense of accountability and
they're able to offer you help and
support when things get tough but not
this who you share your goals with is
extremely important I wouldn't encourage
you to just open up and share it with
everyone and anybody you know over
sharing might not be a positive thing
because these people may end up
sabotaging you oh she's trying to lose
weight how much have you lost
come on one slice of cake will not hurt
you the harsh truth is not everybody
will be excited about your goals there
will always be that one or two people
who have tried to bring you down and you
don't need that energy in your life only
share with those who truly care and want
the best for you together you can keep
each other updated get tips advice and
support each other and the final tip is
to remember this is not just another new
year resolution it is a permanent
lifestyle change it's not something you
do and then stop once you've lost X
amount of weight but rather it is about
setting a pathway to a healthier and
happier life forever so you got to work
towards achieving your goals every
single day forget about going on the
fast lane and because this is a journey
there will be lots of ups and downs okay
I can tell you right now it won't be
smooth and it won't be easy on some days
you will
extremely motivated and on certain days
you might fall back into your all habit
of binge eating if you can foresee this
you can better prepare yourself when
it's about to happen and overcome it
with certain strategies just remember do
not turn relapses or temporary failures
into meltdowns or excuses for giving up
instead acknowledge the mistake and look
for ways on how you can better manage it
and recommit to the past I believe that
achieving our goals isn't about
willpower it is about developing the
right skills and strategies and with the
right execution it will lead to success
so check out my description box below as
I've added a lot of links to guide you
through your fitness journey go ahead
download the lifestyle app and start
today one year from now you will thank
yourself for the decisions and actions
you've taken so start this year strong
and I want you to succeed
what is your fitness goal and how do you
plan on achieving that let me know in
the comments below I wanted to encourage
you to keep me updated on a regular
basis if you find this video to be
helpful do give this video a thumbs up
share with your friends I get them to
join you on this journey subscribe to my
youtube channel for a lot more workout
videos recipes and also fitness tips
guys turn on your notification button so
that you will be the first to be
notified every time I share a new video
all the best and Happy New Year